GO.
>> Sean: GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE HAVE SO MUCH INFORMATION IT
WILL TAKE THE FULL HOUR THAT WE
WILL GIVE YOU TONIGHT BUT I
PROMISE YOU THE MEDIA MOTHS, THE
SINGLE MOST REPUGNANT CORRUPT
WINE GROUP OF PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY WITH A POLITICAL AGENDA
FOR ONE PARTY, WE ARE GOING TO
LAY OUT THE TRUTH EACH AND EVERY
DETAIL WITH THE PRESIDENT DID
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING WRONG.
NOTHING.
THE DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA, THEY
ARE JUST OUTRIGHT LYING TO YOU
AGAIN.
THREE YEARS OF LIES, COVERUPS,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, AND A HOAX,
THEY ARE DOING IT ALL OVER
AGAIN.
AND THIS IS FROM THE COUNTRY, I
WILL TELL YOU THIS, IF YOU LOVE
OUR COUNTRY, AND I
KNOW YOU DO, THIS IS AN ALL
HANDS ON DECK MOMENT.
THIS IS ABOUT OUR WAY OF LIFE.
THIS IS ABOUT OUR SYSTEM OF
GOVERNANCE THAT HAS BEEN THE
SINGLE GREATEST SYSTEM EVER
CREATED BY MANKIND THAT HAS A
RANGE OF THE STANDARD OF LIVING
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD.
LIFE, LIBERTY, THE SUITOR FOR
HAPPINESS.
YOU BELIEVE IN THAT, FREEDOM,
OUR RIGHTS, YOU REALLY NEED TO
ENGAGE NOW LIKE YOU NEVER HAVE
BEEN BECAUSE THE DAY ON THE
OTHER SIDE ALONG WITH THEIR
COHORTS ARE UNHOLY ALLIANCE, THE
MEDIA MILD, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, ONE IN THE
SAME, BECAUSE WHAT THEY ARE
DOING IS SO DANGEROUS, WANTING
TO UNDO AN ELECTION AT ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES, THAT IF THEY
SUCCEED, IF WE INHERIT IT AS
AMERICANS WILL BE
UNRECOGNIZABLE.
AS WE SPEAK, WHAT IS HAPPENING,
THEY ARE ATTEMPTING TO REMOVE A
DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT FROM
OFFICE BASED ON NOTHING BUT A
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
NOW A SECOND WITCH HUNT, AFTER
THREE YEARS OF THE FIRST
WITCH HUNT, NO COLLUSION, WELL,
THEY NOW STARTED ANOTHER ONE BUT
THIS WHEN THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
MAKE THIS A MISTAKE WHICH IS WE
ARE NOT GOING TO WAIT THREE
YEARS AND THEN GET DISAPPOINTED
IN THE END.
THIS IS DEVOID OF ACTUAL CRIMES,
MISDEMEANORS, EVEN MINOR
IMPROPRIETY DOESN'T EXIST HERE
AND THE GREAT IRONY IS THAT ONCE
AGAIN, IT IS THE DEMOCRATS THAT
ARE GUILTY OF NEARLY EVERY
SINGLE ACCUSATION THEY ARE
THROWING ON THE PRESIDENT YOU
ELECTED THAT THEY WANT TO REMOVE
FROM OFFICE.
RUNNING THEME ON THE LEFT AND
THE MEDIA, THE EVERYTHING THEY
CHOOSE THE PRESIDENT OF THEY
THEMSELVES ARE GUILTY OF DOING.
YOU WANT CLEAR EVIDENCE OF A
QUID PRO QUO?
LOOK NO FURTHER THAN SLEEPY
CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE.
HE IS BRAGGING ABOUT IT.
NOW WHAT ABOUT RUSSIA COLLUSION?
OKAY.
WE HAVE HILLARY CLINTON, YET,
THE DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER WITH
FUNNELED MONEY HIRING AND OFFER
A RESEARCH GROUP AND AN AM I SIX
CHRISTOPHER STEELE THERE.
AS "THE NEW YORK TIMES" CALLED
IT, RUSTED DISH INFORMATION FROM
THE GET-GO.
AND THEN IT WAS USED OF COURSE
TO SPY ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
TRANSITION AND EVEN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
ONE OF NUMEROUS WAYS, THIS
PRESIDENT HAS DEAL WITH THINGS
THAT NO OTHER PRESIDENT HAS DEAL
WITH BEFORE.
NOW WITH THE UKRAINIAN
COLLUSION.
IN 2016, THE DNC CONTRACTOR WAS
PAID HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS.
WHY?
TO PRESSURE UKRAINE AND
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS TO DIG UP
DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP AND TRASH'S
CAMPAIGN AND AS AN ADDED BONUS,
WE DO HAVE FOUR U.S. SENATORS,
LESSEE, MENDEZ, MURPHY, LADY,
OH, DICK DURBIN.
THEY ARE ALL ON RECORDS RUNNING
THE GOVERNMENT OF UKRAINE WITH
UNTOLD CONSEQUENCES THAT IF THEY
DON'T COMPLY WITH THEIR
ANTI-TRUMP DEMANDS AND THEIR
INVESTIGATION WITCH HUNT FROM
THE RUSSIA ISSUE.
IT WEARS ALL THE HYSTERIA OVER
THAT THOSE PARTICLES CLOSE?
FOR EXAMPLE, HILLARY PAID FOR
RUSSIAN LIES AND INFLUENCE THE
CAMPAIGN.
NOBODY SAID A THING AFTER SHE
STOLE A PRIMARY, READ IT, AFTER
SHE HAD RIGGED INVESTIGATION
THAT SHE KEPT HER IN THE RACE
AND THEN SHE GETS THE INSURANCE
POLICY.
WHAT ABOUT THE HYSTERIA OVER ALL
OF THOSE EXAMPLES OF COLLUSION?
ONLY IF IT'S TRUMP.
WHERE ARE THE EYE BELIEVERS
SURROUNDING A DEMOCRATIC
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR IN VIRGINIA?
YOU KNOW WHAT, WE'RE WE ARE
WATCHING HERE IS A PATTERN OF
HOLDING AND IT'S SORT OF
QUICKENING NOW AND THAT IS THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO WAIT THREE
YEARS.
WE WILL JUST IMPEACH HIM.
LET'S PICK IT OUT OF A HAT AND
THE MOB OF COURSE SUPPORTS IT
WITH NOSE LOGIC, NO FACTS, NO
REASON.
YOU HAVE TO SUSPEND EVERY BIT OF
GOD-GIVEN INTELLIGENCE AND
COMMON SENSE YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE
THERE IS TO THIS AND WE WILL
HAVE ALL THE DETAILS ABOUT THE
HYPOCRISY COMING UP TONIGHT.
NOW, WE DO HAVE JOE BIDEN'S
CAMPAIGN.
THEY WANT TO ACTUALLY STOP AT
RUDY GIULIANI FROM TALKING.
THEY DEMANDING TV EXECUTIVES
BLOCK HIM FROM APPEARING ON
SHOWS LIKE OURS.
BY THE WAY, THEY DON'T WANT HIM
EXPOSING THE TRUTH ABOUT WHAT
JOE DID WITH THE PROSECUTOR
APPEARED WHY WOULD A
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WANT A
UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR FIRED OR
HE'S GOING TO WITHHOLD
$6 BILLION AND BY THE WAY YOU
ONLY HAVE SIX HOURS TO DO IT?
THERE WOULD BE A SHAKEDOWN BY
BIDEN WITH THE REASON OF THAT'S
RIGHT.
HE WANTS TO PROTECT HIS SON WHO
HAD NO EXPERIENCE IN UKRAINE,
OIL, GAS, OR ENERGY AND WAS
GETTING PAID A FORTUNE.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND RUDY GIULIANI ABOUT IT WAS
JUST SUBPOENAED BY HOUSE
DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE ONE OF THE
GREATEST SHOWS ON EARTH.
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE THAT.
RUDY GIULIANI WILL JOIN US IN A
MOMENT AND HIS BODY WOULD LIKE
TO DEFEND HIS ACTIONS AS
VICE PRESIDENT, WE HAVE INVITED
HIM ON THE SHOW APPEARED I'LL GI
HIM ON THE SHOW APPEARED I'LL GM
HIM ON THE SHOW APPEARED I'LL GA
HIM ON THE SHOW APPEARED I'LL GW
HIM ON THE SHOW APPEARED I'LL GO
HIM ON THE SHOW APPEARED I'LL GE
HIM ON THE SHOW APPEARED I'LL GW
HIM ON THE SHOW APPEARED I'LL G'
HIM ON THE SHOW APPEARED I'LL GS
WORTH OF SHOWS.
HIGH SHOWING CABLE.
YOU CAN JOIN US RIGHT HERE FIVE
NIGHTS IN A ROW.
WE WILL EVEN GIVE HIM THREE
HOURS OF MY RADIO SHOW.
WE ARE MORE ON THAT.
THE FIRST, WE DO HAVE MAJOR
BREAKING NEWS THAT IS
DEVASTATING TO OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
ONCE AGAIN, THE CONTENTS OF YET
ANOTHER PRIVATE PHONE CALL
BETWEEN OUR PRESIDENT AND A
WORLD LEADER WAS LEAKED THIS
TIME TO "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THIS IS NOW THE FOURTH TIME, THE
FOURTH EXAMPLE, LEAKING THE
PRESIDENT'S CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS WITH WORLD
LEADERS.
LET'S SEE, AUSTRALIA AND THEN
MEXICO COME UKRAINE, AND
AUSTRALIA AGAIN.
GERALDO PUT IT WELL.
THIS PRESIDENT IS BEING FORCED
TO DEAL WITH SNITCHES AND RATS
AND BACK STABBERS FOR THREE
YEARS.
PEOPLE WITHIN OUR GOVERNMENT
TRYING TO ESTABLISH AS AN
UNDERMINE AND UNDO AN ELECTION.
WHAT OTHER PRESIDENT HAS EVER
HAD TO DEAL WITH THIS?
THINK ABOUT IT.
EACH DAY PRESIDENT TRUMP NOW HAS
TO WORK AGAINST POWERFUL
UNELECTED DEEP STATE BUREAUCRATS
THAT HATE HIM.
HOW DOES HE GET TO DO HIS JOB?
AT WHAT POINT DOES THIS BECOME
DANGEROUS?
FOR THE ENTIRE WORLD IF HE CAN'T
NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH WITH
WORLD LEADERS?
WHAT WORLD LEADER WILL EVER TALK
TO THE PRESIDENT AND CONFIDENCE
ON A PHONE CALL?
AND SOME OF THESE BAD ACTORS NOW
SPY ON THE PRESIDENT'S
COMMUNICATIONS AND LINK THEM TO
THE MEDIA.
IT IS A MASSIVE NATIONAL
SECURITY CRISIS.
WHO IS SPYING AND LEAKING THIS
INFORMATION?
CALLS BETWEEN WORLD LEADERS MUST
BE SOME OF THE REGARDED
CONVERSATIONS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WORLD LEADERS MUST BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE FREELY AND CLEARLY
WITH OUR PRESIDENT.
THAT WOULD BE GOOD FOR WORLD
PEACE, NEGOTIATION, OUR ECONOMY,
BUT THAT'S NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN
AGAIN.
IF THE TRUST IS NOW FOREVER BEEN
BROKEN.
THE WORLD IS LESS SAFE BECAUSE
OF WHAT THESE PEOPLE ARE DOING.
ABUSING THE POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE THAT WE ENTRUST TO
THEM KEEP US SAFE, NOT TO USE AS
POLITICAL WEAPONRY AGAINST
AMERICAN CITIZENS OR AN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT.
SO FAR, WE HAVE SEEN LINKS, AS I
SAID, NEXT TO AUSTRALIA AND
UKRAINE AND NOW WE HAVE ANOTHER
LEAK WITH THE USE AUSTRALIAN
PRIME MINISTER.
IF THIS IS HOW BUSINESS IS GOING
TO BE CONDUCTED, IT'S PROBABLY
TIME WE GET THE CONTENTS OF SOME
OTHER PEOPLE'S CALLS, OTHER
PRESIDENTS, FOR EXAMPLE.
HOW ABOUT OBAMA'S CONVERSATION
CONVERSATION --
I WILL HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY
AFTER THE ELECTION?
I'D LOVE TO HEAR THE AFTER THE
ELECTION CALLS AND THE PROMISE
HE MADE TO VLADIMIR PUTIN OR HOW
ABOUT THE FULL TRANSCRIPT OF
OBAMA'S CALLS WITH THE PEOPLE IN
IRAN?
THAT LED UP TO THIS HORRIBLE
NUCLEAR DEAL AND HIM GETTING $1I
NUCLEAR DEAL AND HIM GETTING $1L
NUCLEAR DEAL AND HIM GETTING $1O
NUCLEAR DEAL AND HIM GETTING $1N
NUCLEAR DEAL AND HIM GETTING $1T
NUCLEAR DEAL AND HIM GETTING $1O
NUCLEAR DEAL AND HIM GETTING $1E
NUMBER ONE STATE SPONSOR OF
TERROR THAT WANT TO WIPE ISRAEL
AND THE U.S. OFF THE MAP?
WHILE YOU'RE AT IT, WHY DON'T WE
GET MIGHT BIDEN'S COMMUNICATIONS
AND PHONE CALLS AND
TRANSCRIPTION OF THE LEADERS
THAT HE TALKED TO WITH UKRAINE?
THAT'S WHEN HIS SON GOT THAT
LUCRATIVE DEAL.
IS THAT WHAT THEY WANT?
BY THE WAY, WHAT WAS THE BIG
SO-CALLED BOMBSHELL DEVELOPMENT
FROM THE MOST RECENTLY -- GO
LOOK AT "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
PRESIDENT TRUMP REQUESTED THE
AUSTRALIAN GOVERNMENT THAT THEY
COOPERATE WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S INVESTIGATION
INTO WHAT IS THE ORIGIN OF THE
RUSSIA PROBE.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE DOJ OFFICIAL
IS NOW TELLING FOX NEWS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL DID AS THE
PRESIDENT TO MAKE STANDARD
INTRODUCTIONS TO OFFICIALS IN
MULTIPLE COUNTRIES WHO MAY HAVE
PERTINENT INFORMATION IN THE
ONGOING PROBE.
NOW ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, THESE REQUESTS ARE
NOT OUT OF THE ORDINARY AT ALL
AND SO FAR THE COUNTRIES HAVE
BEEN VERY HELPFUL WITHOUT ANY
NEED FOR PRESSURE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE AND YOU WON'T LIKELY
HEAR THIS FROM THE MEDIA MAULED,
YOU SEE, THIS IS THE PART OF THE
STORY AND THE RUSSIA WITCH HUNT
THAT THEY DIDN'T WANT TO PAY
ATTENTION TO.
YES, WE ARE GOING TO GET THE
STORY ON FISA ABUSE AND THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT.
WE WILL ALSO GET THOSE BARR
DURUM REPORT ALSO AND THE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THIS RUSSIA
WITCH HUNT.
THE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
NONPARTISAN INVESTIGATION.
A BIG PIECE OF THE PROBE
SURROUNDS WHETHER OR NOT OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND TELL PEOPLE
AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS, WHETHER
THEY TRIED TO CIRCUMVENT
UNITED STATES LAW AND SPY ON
AMERICAN CITIZENS BY SIMPLY
CIRCUMVENTING THE LAW AND
OUTSOURCING AND SUBCONTRACTING
THE ILLEGAL SURVEILLANCE TO
INTEL AGENCIES IN FOREIGN
COUNTRIES LIKE GREAT BRITAIN,
CAN YOU DO ME A FAVOR?
I NEED INFORMATION ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ITALY, DO YOU MIND SPYING ON OUR
PRESIDENT?
AUSTRALIA.
YEAH.
ALL OF THOSE COUNTRIES ARE BEING
LOOKED INTO AS HAVING DONE THAT
FOR, YES, OUR OWN INTELLIGENCE
PEOPLE BECAUSE LEGALLY THEY
CAN'T SO THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE
BEING CUTE TRYING TO GET AROUND
THAT LAW.
SO IT'S PRETTY CLEAR WHY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE NEEDS TO
BE WORKING WITH AUSTRALIA AND
ITALY AND AUTHORITIES IN
GREAT BRITAIN TO PROBE INTO THE
ORIGINS OF A RUSSIA WITCH HUNT
HAS A VERY REAL INVESTIGATION
INTO REAL SERIOUS GOVERNMENT
ABUSE OF POWER AND CORRUPTION.
DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA, THEY HAVE
NEVER TOLD YOU THAT STORY.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT ACTUAL
CRIMES.
IF THE DAY, THEY WOULD'VE
CLEARLY SEEN WHAT WE DID A
SLAM-DUNK CASE WHEN
HILLARY CLINTON COMMITTED
MULTIPLE CRIMES IN THE ESPIONAGE
ACT.
THEY WOULD'VE SEEN THAT WHEN IT
SAYS THAT THE TOP OF THE PHIS
APPLICATION VERIFIED AND YOU
DON'T VERIFY IT AND YOU USE
RUSSIAN LIES JUST BY ON A
CAMPAIGN AND THEN A TRANSITION
TEAM AND THEN A PRESIDENCY AND
THEN DENY ANOTHER AMERICAN THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS, YET, THEY
WOULD'VE TOLD YOU THAT STORY TOO
BUT THEY CONVENIENTLY LEFT IT
OUT.
INSTEAD, THE LEFT IS TOTALLY
CONSUMED WITH HATRED FOR ALL
THINGS DONALD TRUMP.
IN FACT, THEY HAVE SPENT ONLY
THE LAST THREE YEARS TRYING TO
FIND SOME WAY, ANYWAY, TO
IMPEACH HIM.
HE WAS BUSTER.
THE MOB BEGAN FAULT CALLING FOR
IMPEACHMENT ONLY TWO DAYS AFTER
HE GOT ELECTED.
THE NEXT 35 CONSECUTIVE MONTHS,
GUESS WHAT, MORE AND MORE CALLS
FOR IMPEACHMENT.
IMPEACHMENT, IMPEACHMENT,
IMPEACHMENT, WHAT IS JUST OF THE
COUNTRY, THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY CARE ABOUT PEACE AND
PROTECTING OUR COUNTRY.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT THAT EITHER.
THEY CARE ABOUT ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AND JOBS AND THE
ECONOMY.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WILL FIGHT EVERY DAY UNTIL
HE IS IMPEACHED.
IMPEACH 45.
>> DONALD TRUMP NOW SITS AT THE
THRESHOLD OF IMPEACHMENT.
>> GIVEN THE EVENTS OF TODAY,
LOOK THE LIKELIHOOD OF
IMPEACHMENT, I'M NOT SAYING
NECESSARILY BUT IT CERTAINLY WEN
NECESSARILY BUT IT CERTAINLY WET
OUT.
SPEAK OF THE CONSTITUTION CANNOT
BE ANY CLEARER.
IMPEACHMENT IS THE APPROPRIATE
REMEDY.
>> WE ARE GOING TO GO IN THERE
AND WE ARE GOING TO KICK SOME --
I AM TOLD BY THE HOUSE TO
INITIATE IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS.
>> THEY TOLD US ENOUGH TO
INTERPRET WHAT HE SAID AS A
REFERRAL FOR IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS.
>> IT'S TIME FOR US TO IMPEACH
THIS PRESIDENT.
>> THEY ARE CONSIDERING WHAT TO
DO ABOUT IT INCLUDING POSSIBLE
VOTING ON ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
>> THERE SHOULD BE AN
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY OPENED.
>> THEY WERE GOING TO GET
ELECTIONS FROM HER.
YOU SEE ANYTHING MISSING FROM
ALL THIS HYSTERIA?
NO CRIMES, NO MISDEMEANORS, NO
CONSPIRACY, NOTE CONSTRUCTION.
FLANDERS, SMEARING, SUBMERGING,
THAT'S WHAT YOU GET FROM YOUR
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY AND
GOD FORBID THEY EVER GIVE YOU
YOUR GREEN YOUR DEAR AND
MEDICARE FOR ALL THEIR THAT'S
WHAT THEY WANTED SINCE 2016.
NOW DEMOCRATS AND THE MOB, THEY
VALUE VENGEANCE ABOVE ALL ELSE.
THEY ARE SO DISAPPOINTED THAT
THERE LIES DIDN'T BECOME THEIR
REALITY AND THEIR CURRENT
IMPEACHMENT HYSTERIA SURROUNDS
NOTHING THEN WHAT HAS BECOME A
NONSTORY ABOUT WHAT HAS BECOME A
PERFECTLY NORMAL TELEPHONE
CALL BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS UKRAINIAN COUNTERPART.
WE NOW HAVE THE TRANSCRIPT.
THERE WAS NO QUID PRO QUO.
IT WAS NO COLLUSION.
NO MISCONDUCT.
THE UNITED STATES AND CRANE EVEN
HAVE A TREATY THAT ALLOWS THE
TWO COUNTRIES MANDATE THAT WE MN
TWO COUNTRIES MANDATE THAT WE MA
TWO COUNTRIES MANDATE THAT WE ME
TWO COUNTRIES MANDATE THAT WE MT
TWO COUNTRIES MANDATE THAT WE MI
TWO COUNTRIES MANDATE THAT WE MV
TWO COUNTRIES MANDATE THAT WE MS
TWO COUNTRIES MANDATE THAT WE MI
TWO COUNTRIES MANDATE THAT WE MA
TWO COUNTRIES MANDATE THAT WE MN
TWO COUNTRIES MANDATE THAT WE M.
THE PRESIDENT WAS SAYING WE HAVE
ALL THIS TROUBLE WITH OUR
ELECTION AND YOU GUYS ARE THE
PRESIDENT PROBLEM.
THE PRESIDENT BY THE WAY HAS
THIS TO SAY WITH A HYSTERIA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS WHOLE THING IS A
DISGRACE.
THERE'S BEEN TREMENDOUS
CORRUPTION AND THERE'S BEEN
CORRUPTION ON THE OTHER SIDE.
IT IS BEEN CORRUPTION LIKE
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN.
SLOUGH THE NEW PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE RAN ON THE BASIS OF NO
CORRUPTION.
THAT IS HOW HE GOT ELECTED AND I
BELIEVE HE REALLY MEANS IT BUT
THERE WAS A LOT OF CORRUPTION
HAVING TO DO WITH THE 2016
ELECTION AGAINST US AND WE WANT
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT AND
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE DEA
DEAL.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO READ THE
TRANSCRIPTS.
THIS WAS A PERFECTLY NORMAL
LEGAL PHONE CALL.
SO NORMAL IN FACT THAT NO
LEAGUER OR LIAR TO THE COWARDLY
SHIFT --
HE HAD TO MAKE UP HIS OWN
FABRICATED VERSION OF THE
TRANSCRIPT AND PERFORM A
DRAMATIC READING MEANWHILE THERE
ARE SO MANY UNANSWERED QUESTIONS
SURROUNDING THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
THAT'S NOT A WHISTLE-BLOWER AND
THE REPORT AND ALL OF THIS
LEAKING AND THE DANGERS THAT IT
IMPOSES TO THIS COUNTRY AND OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL GOVERNANCE.
WHY?
SO THEY CAN PUSH THIS PRESIDENT
OUT BECAUSE AS ONE CONGRESSMAN
SAID BACK IN MAY, WE CAN'T BEAT